camille qui vivent sur le territoire
innu cette chanson là on l'entend
partout c'est le tube de l'été
atika mais qui nous ça fait un ravage
c'était
tu as
on ne peut pas dire
[Musique]
m
tieger
african a été
avec
m
et les jeunes les filles en particulier
raffole du chanteur scott ian picard et
de son band est ce que vous allez me
faire faire du circuit avec lui tantôt
c'est sûr que sur ce soir des jeunes
finissants sont venus de tous les
villages in ou pour recevoir leur
diplôme de secondaire 5
si ces jeunes étudient en français c'est
en innu qu'ils aiment chanter
pourquoi vous trippé sur la musique il
noie parce que ce genre dans notre
langue pisser d'habitude c'est juste en
anglais puis en français et chansons
pays c'est cool d'avoir une ton qu'on
peut comprendre juste nous autres ne
sait pas gérer quid des communautés tout
le monde veut avoir des circuits avec
nous autres monde de se prendre en photo
au studio de l'artiste florent vollant
le guitariste et arrangeur réjean
bouchard observe cette sous culture
populaire depuis des années c'est des
zones que les gens connaissent pas
disons que les gens ont tendance à
oublier
puis en promenant on a beaucoup avec
florian surtout puis en allant d'un bout
à l'autre du canada
nous sommes content quelqu'un avait il
précisé en province comme ça il ya comme
grandes lignes entre les milieux puis il
ya le nord et le sud
e
si la musique qui nous est en bonne
santé c'est beaucoup grâce au groupe
kashtin qui à la fin des années 80 donné
l'exemple d'une réussite populaire dans
une langue autochtone c'est des traces
j'imagine c'est le résultat des belles
choses aux cons qu'on a fait ensemble
peut-être si je faisais remet d'ailleurs
c'est nos enfants
shawinigan et
les nous ça se chante bien je trouve
déjà mort
mais noah
orly nous est menacée d'extinction dans
la douzaine de villages et nous du
québec et du labrador à peine onze mille
personnes maîtrise encore la langue
essentiellement parce que l'école et en
français quand on dit qu'on est inouï
c'est vraiment c'est culturel on parle
deux langues
on parle de gestes des gestes
millénaires de de chasse de survie de
chants traditionnels c'est tout seul
autre source en innu tu perds la langue
si tu perds un peu du reste c'est ça qui
me quittes que je crée mon beau couple
tard
sma
qui me fontaine a lui-même fait partie
d'un groupe uni célèbre aujourd'hui il
dit les jeux festival innu nikamu d'un
des plus gros festivals de musique
autochtone au canada et qui se déroule
chaque année depuis 34 ans à malioténam
quand tu lances une chanson en innu
c'est un petit peu comme une façon sûre
garder la langue puis ça voyage ça reste
le festival se déroule sur un lieu de
triste mémoire
là où se trouvait un pensionnat
aujourd'hui détruits mais qu'ils
arrachent et de jénine où de la
côte-nord à leur famille et leur culture
de 1952 à 1970 aujourd'hui les musiciens
chantent et font chanter là les
autochtones mais aussi les non
autochtones font c'est une fierté est de
chanter dans ma langue et fiable châtel
dans ma langue et
pis le monde chansons sont fiers aussi
le noir face au mcs christiane et bouba
gong et evan bayh stagner
la raison pour laquelle chambre en
attikameks dans la tour et du camino
c'est pour montrer que je suis
attikameks je suis fier de pratique à
mains puis de le faire montrer aux gens
qui est important de parler la langue
maternelle
la langue autochtone parce qu'il s'agit
aussi grâce aux soldes
si on peut savoir où est ce qu'on peut
reste qu'on gagne une forme de
résistance
[Musique]